ثلاثة فنانين في كل مكان في جميع أنحاء العالم ولكن
الخوف مختلف تمامًا في مدن مختلفة جدًا
نعرف نيويورك أنت
تعرف باريس ولكني أريد أن يعرف الناس
حبيبة سنغافورة اسمي حديقة الحيوانات
المعروفة باسمك وأنا مباشرة
في هذه سنغافورة تشتهر
بمساحاتها الخضراء  وقد أمرت الطبيعة المتمردة في
النمسا بأنها لا تتناسب مع
سيطرة سنغافورة الأكبر ، لكنني أعتقد
أن هذا ما يجعل الأمر ممتعًا لأنني
كنت في الأماكن العامة حيث تكون الأعمال في
متناول الجميع ، ما أفعله
دائمًا مجاني للأشخاص الذين سيشاهدونهم
عمل آخر في مساحة لم
يتوقعوا مني مطلقًا ، أعتقد أن هذا هو جماله
بمجرد اكتماله ، فهو ينتمي إلى
الفضاء العام ، لذلك يتم إزالته في
غضون ساعة ، لا بأس من أن يكون
سنغافورة بلدًا صغيرًا
يتغير كل شيء بسرعة كبيرة
ويعكس فن الشارع جيدًا أنني
[موسيقى]
انخرطت لأول مرة في فن الشارع مباشرة
بعد خدمتي العسكرية في أوائل
العشرينات من عمري ، كنت أتزلج على الألواح ، وكان الأمر
أشبه بموسيقى عامة  من التعاطف بالنسبة لي
للانتقال من جزء من ثقافة الشارع
إلى جزء آخر عندما بدأت للتو في
الخروج في الشوارع كنت أكثر
قلقًا بشأن مجرد عملية
الرسم التي
أقوم بها الآن لمدة 15 عامًا
أفكر في عملية سرد القصص
ثم ماذا  أريد أن أعبر كفنانة في
الغالب عن اهتمامي بالتعبير عن
الحالة الإنسانية خاصة في
المجتمع الحضري لأن
هذا هو المكان الذي أكون فيه ومن هنا نشأت ، ومن هنا
حصلت على أفكار من عام 2013 حصلت على
جائزة الفنانين الشباب من National  يعد Arts
Council ، الذي يعد الأول من نوعه لفناني الشوارع
، أحد المعالم البارزة في مسيرتي
المهنية لأنني أمثل
مجتمعًا من الفنانين الذين دائمًا
ما يكونون على الهامش لأن الحياة العامة
تمنحني المزيد من الحافز للقيام بأعمال أفضل
والدعوة إلى فن الشارع.
خاصة في سياق سنغافورة
لخلق أشياء جديدة هو كسر كل
شيء وإعادة صنعه
الابتكار هو اضطراب
[موسيقى]